Thomas Bryant 15 plus points rather than
10 plus points if we can get the parlay
on the screen in its current iteration
or
Luca over eight and a half assists
rather than eight plus assists so
there's a comment in here Kelly Bean is
saying make it eight since Ryan's
talking about spiders and that's pretty
I like that Vibe I don't know
um
no no man
I thought I was talking about the eight
assists versus eight and a half oh okay
all right do you want to make it Kelly
if you want us to make it an eight leg
parlay just say the word and we'll do it
don't make those promises uh beat b
Thompson said uh
Thomas 15 points so did Jaquan
make it 15 plus hey B Thompson B
Thompson can we make this your play
because I know you say you came in here
and you said no no just the Thomas Bryan
he came in here and said you don't take
you don't take my picks I Thomas Bryan I
will I'm willing to give to you as your
pick
I see a lot of a lot I see a lot of
support at 15 for Brian 15. yeah so this
is what we have currently we have Luca
doncic eight plus assists Thomas Bryant
10 plus points Thomas Bryant eight plus
rebounds Robert Williams six plus
rebounds Jason Tatum 25 plus points
I would also be willing to move Thomas
Bryant to the 15 plus
let's do it let's see what it looks like
all right
480 again
call it a parlay I was wrong indeed
Kelly Bean is checking me and saying
spider parlay give me eight legs
I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding yeah
hey
basket this one feels good
yeah this one feels good I don't know
why do you have that face uh
uh I just it feels like why like why are
we doing like I don't know
six legs is a lot like we we just we we
came onto the show and we were like we
were struggling to hit so let's hit
something and now I feel like we have
six legs just to have six legs when we
could have we could have just been
riding Jason Tatum 35 Plus points all
along
didn't we do 30 no we did 25. that's
cool wow yeah I like it it's good all
right well all right well look at this
take out Williams rebounds and put Jason
Tatum 30 points and see we'll react
yeah see he'll want to do that no it's
just like is that gonna do much for us
we'll see we'll see if what are you
trying to do okay right I'm trying to
get us to at least plus 500. that's
actually no and that's the problem that
is the problem wow that's the problem
you're getting greedy you're trying to
force it you're forcing it you're
forcing it and every week you force it
and then
this is this sounds like pent-up
frustration from you Greg
why can't I you
said plus 500 when you don't need to we
we had to lock that plus five plus three
Thirty
no I like this
see because it's plus 500. that is
correct that is why I like it yes
Prince by Prince in the chat saying a
win is a win I gotta go with the people
in Greg tonight man we've we've done
your parlay the last three weeks man if
it's plus 480 for six legs it doesn't
matter because the money is gonna cash
and we're gonna have and my mandarian's
gonna get a chance to take his lady to
dinner you wanna you wanna make be
responsible for him not taking his lady
to dinner I don't want to live with that
on my conscience uh no I don't I don't
want to be responsible for that I also
said I would like to do the same thing
yo what's up I'm sorry I didn't mean to
cut you off I was just going to read a
comment from people no go ahead I was
just gonna recap the parlay so look oh
rock paper scissors
Bandit Bandit zero one nine says uh
that's how you lose betting to get
specific odds the people
and you are you are a man of the people
D you have to listen king of the king of
the rats actually please
you gotta listen to the people
I am listening to the people
so make it make it plus 480 again so we
could get out of here
all right so like if if you're listening
to the people take Luca down the six
sixes no no no no we by the way also we
so this is a five leg parlay we have
four legs we have four we have four yeah
so here it is we have four legs in the
same in the same game we have Luca eight
plus assists Thomas Bryant eight plus
rebounds LeBron 30 plus points Thomas
Bryant 15 plus points and Jason Tatum 30
plus points do we wanna like that's also
my other thing here it's like here goes
Ryan I just like there's four legs in
the same game here you go
it's four legs
who cares
what I'm saying who cares
okay chat
this is a all right we'll scroll we'll
scroll through again
wait what did we take out wasn't it six
legs Luca
right
we took out we took out Robert Williams
yeah we had six rebounds that that's a
lock that is a lot like yeah but he
didn't do anything for us it was like
minus three thousand
Ryan I don't think you understand man
that's what I'm saying I'm saying bro
Robert Williams is made of glass I don't
think you guys understand if we'd be
lucky if he finished this game
he just rested for a whole game that
doesn't mean anything
oh my God I don't Greg I don't want I
don't want you to have to tell them to
put Ryan's parlay on here again but okay
it feels like this is what's gonna
happen is that what is come on man this
is happening week after week Ryan would
this make you guys feel better if we did
it this way if we added Robert Williams
no what we're gonna do is take Tatum
back down to 25. yes
tell him and me
can you go can can we do that please
I'll feel a lot better
thank you Ryan thank you so much
there we go boom plus 480. let's go get
this cash man so what is it what's the
bet what's the bet
let's do you hear the depression in his
voice just wait here comes a three two
one we have Luca doncic eight plus
assist Thomas Bryant a plus rebounds
LeBron James 30 plus points Thomas
Bryant Legacy game apparently 15 plus
points Robert Williams six plus rebounds
Jason Tatum 25 plus points that is six
legs yeah I like this 480. hey I'm not
gonna lie though I'm not gonna lie don't
lie
take Luca assist to six
[Laughter]
no we're not doing that
the only reason why we're not doing that
is because we got with it was the first
comment before the show even started so
he gave us eight that's three times
that's true that's be Thompson's leg
that's B Thompson's leg uh
Darian says I need some milk I have I've
hit
I wish I was at the by the fridge I
would have got you something
I'm good with
good with the chat chat thumbs up thumbs
down if we're good with this six leg
parlay at plus 480. double O says LeBron
is not dropping 30 tonight in all caps
we're nice just jump to plus 530 what
what moved
Thomas Bryant of course and LeBron
my and Thomas Bryant again I'll take the
LeBron leg as my leg and I don't care
because he is literally just
he's just watching for this record that
he's gonna break I swear and he knows
that if he has 35 tonight he's gonna get
all of his followers and they're gonna
lose by 15. it's perfect I've already
watched it happen
the only thing that's like the only
thing that like has me second guessing
or thinking this parlay is Luca's assist
I feel like personally he's more
dependent as far as in a rebounder
than throwing assists because like he
scores a lot
uh rebounds uh sorry uh the snake said
six plus rebounds
oh snake versus
yeah El Bay also says Luca rebound so I
don't want you thinking that I'm pushing
any propaganda Ryan
um no I see that's the difference
between you and I I don't accuse you of
pushing propaganda I listen I absorb I'm
like a sponge Greg I take everything I
take the hate I take the slander
[Applause]
somebody said a sponge and locks that's
so funny
all right six plus rebounds nah it's
just like it doesn't 10 50.
ah guys what are we doing
we're close to Kelly's eight leg spider
parlay take off your assist take off the
assist
off yeah just watch watch watch why not
not for six legs not for six legs I
liked what we had before
what's the difference
when like
what's almost a whole dollar yeah almost
yeah wait hold on what's his oh I don't
like that oh wait his assist jump to
nine and a half that's good for us yeah
so let's leave it at eight before they
move that [ __ ] again
I'm about to get fired
you could you could curse over here yeah
you can I'm just fired up man I'm trying
to win and I think the eight is the lock
yeah I think so too I I like what we
have uh do we want to recap it one more
time and then again Final Call 5 30.
yeah yeah oh yeah let's go
Thomas Bryant man is gonna the 15 plus
is really gonna just give it seven no no
this Luca eight assists is really gonna
sit with me 86
so we don't what if you moved what if
you moved Bryant down to 10 now that
it's plus 534. all right
uh
this is scary this is scary I don't know
what we're
there was a big five gosh what happened
I don't know what happened yeah how do
we yeah
we feel it seems like we feel
significantly worse about this no I I
don't necessarily but I just don't know
why the odds moved so much like
anyway I'm cool with the I'm cool with
the Thomas Bryant uh 15. yeah me too the
Lucas stuff moved in the right direction
for us I'm cool with Luca I'm more cool
and I was also that was the one we kind
of have to we OB Thompson won wait time
out timeout Beach do you like that Luca
player do you like another one comment
if you like another one
it's like yeah I'm down I'm down to keep
it but if you like anything else you
just let us know oh he just said when
Luca ate assist hit and y'all don't take
it I'ma personally hit you up Greg all
right we gotta ride with it yeah
Darien 85 15 points for Thomas Bryan is
scary uh we got Kyrie two plus threes in
here
no the Kyrie we looked at Kyrie two plus
threes it's not it doesn't look good and
the Thomas for ten points isn't good no
it's not what if what if we have we have
to have make a decision on time as well
right now do we just take his his over
under which I believe what is it 11 and
a half or something like that
okay wait
okay your guys are not gonna love this
what if we take what if we take the the
Thomas Bryant points out and we bump
Tatum to 30 plus
don't hate that here you go nah nope
Greg this is it thank you thank you I
don't hate that why
because just why we're gonna change the
number that much G it's gonna It's Gonna
Get Us I you don't care about winning
right you don't you say that don't you
put that on me that is not true
I win over 500 plus 500. no I'm cool
with this if we want to sit up if we
want to settle on plus 461 with these
five that is what I will do
I'm cool with this let's take out Thomas
hey let's let's get let's get Thomas
Bryant templates points out of there
that's
don't let's not do that I don't want to
do that
Thomas Bryant what is like over under
Thomas because I'm seeing a lot of
Bryant 11 and a half points
it was 16 and a half oh wow okay yeah no
we're good on that
I don't know how you guys find it out I
I don't dislike Jason Tatum to go over
30 points but it's just proves my point
it's just Ryan pushing his propaganda on
our parlay
we have to take the power from you at
least one week if he goes for 45 then
fine whatever
hey if you guys want to scroll FanDuel
then I was just going to say next show
let me scroll FanDuel and uh man
I don't know I've been I've been Rana
six says Greg let him know we need
winners only come on man that's what I'm
trying to win I'm trying to win Ryan I'm
sorry I'm normally the middle man and
I'm the devil's advocate but it sounds
like we're gonna have to go back to 25
points
and we're gonna have to we're just gonna
have to ride with the original I think
that's I think that's the way hey look
at it look at ovs 33 turn it into Ryan's
parlay eye rolls
oh God Jaquan Jaquan says Ryan is
pissing me off okay Jaquan what do you
want
it's like what do you what do you want
though hold you told you what we wanted
Ryan we had it
you want Thomas you want the Thomas
Bryant points back yes the people yeah
that's what we're doing
ready so we're doing a six leg parlay
I love how upset you kidding it's really
funny
said royce royce O'Neill 25 points plus
please
now we're getting to the troll we're
getting to the trolling part
of the chat now
did this okay okay Big Meech this guy
Ryan makes you lose place place the part
place the damn parlay now and call it a
day all right all right I'm taking
enough heat here I'll concede 15 plus
yeah
there it is all right there it is yep
yep yep yep there it is let's win this
when this hits I'm so I'm I'm gonna lose
it I'm gonna lose it somebody said oval
Rose says if this turns into the Ryan
parlay I'm not tailing okay guess what
Every Rose Ryan lost US money last week
hey hey Darien 85 says guess me and my
lady eating at Wendy's for dinner
Ryan didn't have too much say so on this
one
and that's the determining factor for
you
I mean the last three weeks I mean you
know what what what the people are
saying is they have more faith in Thomas
Bryant than they do on producer Ryan so
I've never been more disrespected on
this show before I will say that
can you read the parlay one more time
and then just know that when this hits
the chat is going to be on fire next
week I just can't wait to see it I can't
wait to see it all right let's do this
uh let's do it it's Thomas Bryant eight
plus rebounds LeBron James 30 plus
points Luka doncic eight plus assists
Thomas Bryant Legacy game 15 plus points
Robert Williams six plus rebounds and
Jason Tatum 25 plus points plus 546. six
likes this time not five six
I say check marks by B Thompson he's in
favor and remember you're putting this
in on FanDuel you're getting your money
back if it loses but it will not because
Ryan Ryan had no say in the end of the
parlay so we're all gonna eat yeah we're
good
I feel real good about this one right uh
what man you already read the parlay
you're read it one more time for the
people
entertainment
you can read the parlay because he had
no say in it
I'll do it one more time just for you
Greg why not
a plus assist Thomas Bryant eight plus
rebounds Thomas Bryant 15 plus points
Jason Tate of 25 plus points LeBron
James 30 plus points Robert Williams six
plus rebounds plus 546 the chats parlay
the chat is all over the chat was all
over this one today Ryan you're gonna
sleep out for a letter tonight knowing
that like you had nothing to do with
this either way so I feel like this is a
win-win for you that is yeah yeah but I
don't know I have a lot of ammo now I
can there's a lot of blame that I can
pass I would never because Greg you know
this I'm not and I Told You So guy oh
you're a big one big I Told You So Guy
what's your record on this show
what do you mean it's a record it's the
it's a parlay it was no record no no no
no no no
you didn't get the joke you didn't it's
okay we'll move on if you guys want to
tell our five leg parlay make sure you
head on over to FanDuel and up into the
TNT Thursdays no sweat parlay for a free
bet if it loses
we're not grading any bets today we're
about to get up out of here
Ryan
they told me to have you read the parlay
one more time but I'm not gonna do that
to you
I'm not gonna do that to you the people
in the control room are clowning me just
as much as you guys by the way on a
daily basis I just want you to know that
they told me to have you read the parlay
but you guys see the parlay right there
uh Ryan did not have much say so in this
parlay so we are in good hands people we
are in good hands MB uh let's Get on Up
out of here Ryan and MB my name is Greg
Ivy next to me is MB I call him MB you
guys might know him as Michael Bowlen I
have to make that clear he is the man of
the app and next to him is the man we
all love
we love you bro producer Ryan
AKA King of the rats AKA a man of the
people
hey we're up out of here y'all peace
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]